it's Jasmine and Kate thank you to
BuzzFeed and biator for sending us to
the beautiful city by the bay for a
weekend getaway let's use the Viator app
okay we have a secret mission food tour
booked this is La Vaca birya it actually
is inside of the old discolandia record
store here their specialty is the Lydia
Taco they're going to give you a little
cup of the consummate and then you're
gonna dip the taco in
look at that this is beautiful welcome
to El matate the owner here makes a very
unique and special fish taco lime on
we're here at media Noche I'm gonna get
you the most delicious sandwiches both
their traditional Cubano sandwich and a
version of the Cubano made with a sweet
brioche bread this is dandelion
chocolate almost like drinking a melted
chocolate bar wow thank you so much Mark
thank goodness proprietor I don't know
where we'd be without them but I'm glad
we have them